[Applaudissements]
abbas et pouvait me demandez pas ce que
ma vie a changé ya pas longtemps exclue
dans les voitures et non elle mais vous
quand même et puis la coke 21 lacombe
raté un vélo la conférence
internationale sur le long du tracé à
paris voilà ça m'a vraiment interpellé
sur ce qu'on pouvait faire au quotidien
un petit chose qu'on pouvait faire pour
l'environnement et avant je paye dans la
voiture mais comme ça dure très
longtemps ou le savez 4 5 heures du coup
dans la voiture c'est un sauna du coup
je laissais le moteur allumé la clim et
si j'ai appris c'est très mauvais au
loin on entend toutes les demi-heures
votre une quinzaine par connaître en
plus pour les gros maintenant je fais
dans la voiture je commande préliminaire
dans la voiture et après ils sur le
capot comme ça il n'y a pas trop chaude
[Applaudissements]